as we get into the 1500s the renaissance
has been going on for roughly 200 years
especially europe has been rediscovering
the knowledge from the greeks and from
the romans and as they enter into the
16th century they start to go beyond the
knowledge of the greeks and the romans
in 1543 nicolas copernicus publishes on
the revolutions of the heavenly spheres
famous for suggesting that earth is not
the center of the universe but that the
earth revolves around the sun
what was powerful about this is it
challenged centuries-old ideas about how
the universe worked and at a meta level
it was about using new methods and
evidence in order to make conclusions no
matter how revolutionary those
conclusions might be
and this publication is often cited as
the beginning of what will be known as
the scientific revolution
many people view the capstone of the
scientific revolution to be
newton's publication of principia in
1687
and this is an incredibly powerful
publication it describes the laws of the
universe it's a universe in which most
things can be explained with simple
principles with mathematics this is so
powerful that it would not be challenged
for over 200 years until albert einstein
comes on the scene with his theories of
relativity but even today
newton's laws this is what is taught in
a first-year physics class this is what
you will learn in an introductory
engineering class so there's many things
to think about why did this happen at
this period in time how was it related
to the renaissance how is it related to
things that were happening in politics
in europe at the time but needless to
say it gave humanity a new perspective
on the universe
and it gave humanity new powers and we
began to challenge all assumptions and
so as we get into the late 1600s and
early 1700s people start trying to use
these same tools the same deductive
reasoning on some of the oldest
questions that humanity has ever asked
itself questions like
what rights do we have as human beings
who gets those rights
what duty and obligation do we have
towards each other
what is the role of government
who has the right to rule
now some of these questions have been
the fodder of philosophers and religion
for thousands of years but now there was
the power and the tools and the
challenging notions of the scientific
revolution and this philosophical
movement that is really tied to the
scientific revolution is known as the
enlightenment
and just to have an example of the
thinking during the enlightenment
here is a passage from john locke who's
considered one of the pillars of the
enlightenment this is published in 1689
it's the second treatise concerning
civil government
the state of nature has a law of nature
to govern it which obliges everyone
and reason which is that law so reason
is the law of nature to govern it
teaches all mankind who will but
consulted that being all equal and
independent no one ought to harm another
in his life health liberty or
possessions
and when his own preservation comes not
in competition
ought he as much as he can to preserve
the rest of mankind and may not unless
it be to do justice on an offender take
away or impair the life or what tends to
the preservation of the life the liberty
health limb or goods of another now to
parse what he's saying he says that
reason is this natural law that should
govern human action
and he's saying no one ought to harm
anyone else and that if we're not in
competition maybe there's only enough
food for one of us and there's two of us
there in which case we'd be in
competition but if there isn't that
competition we should be trying to help
each other and we should be trying to
preserve the rest of mankind and unless
it's for the purpose of justice you
don't have the right to take away or
impair the life or things that help
preserve the life the liberty the health
limb or goods of another now you might
say hey isn't this common sense and
religions for all of time have touched
on some of these issues
but you also have to appreciate that
this is a time when kings and emperors
ruled the world what gave them that
right why are certain people slaves and
other people not slaves why do certain
people in that world have a right to own
these other people and so this was a
very controversial idea challenging some
of these fundamental notions of who
should rule who has the right to rule
and to what degree should people exert
control over one another so given these
challenging notions of the enlightenment
and john locke was only one of the
actors who would figure prominently in
this roughly hundred year period it's no
surprise that as you get into the late
1700s and early 1800s you have a whole
string of revolutions especially in the
americas to a large degree inspired by
the ideas of the enlightenment things
like life liberty health in the united
states declaration of independence these
things are cited during the french
revolution these things are cited in the
various revolutions in latin america
these ideas are cited now one of the
reasons why the enlightenment came about
when it did not only did we have new
tools of thinking and the opportunity to
challenge notions but it might have been
that society now had the responsibility
to think a little bit deeper about these
ideas because it was getting more and
more powers through the scientific
revolution and those powers were
becoming even more significant when that
science was applied during the
industrial revolution
now society could produce more than it
could ever produce before but as we talk
about in other videos the industrial
revolution had a certain hunger for raw
materials and a certain hunger for
markets in which to sell your finished
product it also allowed for more
powerful weapons and ways to project
power and to control a larger empire
methods of communication methods of
force
and many historians tie it directly to
the age of imperialism where especially
western european powers sought areas to
get raw materials and markets in which
they could push their finished products
and so as the industrialized world had
more and more power these ideas of the
enlightenment became maybe even more
relevant even though they might not have
been implemented consistently during the
age of imperialism and as we've seen in
other videos even though the technology
keeps accelerating during the industrial
revolution the philosophy and the moral
framework does not accelerate along with
it and in the 20th century we see one of
the bloodiest centuries in all of human
history so let me leave you with a final
series of questions as we go into the
1800s we talked about the various
independence movements especially in the
americas we also have the abolishing of
slavery in most of the world around this
time period and so to some degree it
looks like the ideas of the
enlightenment are coming to be but at
the exact same time you have the age of
imperialism where more and more control
is exerted over people around the planet
this all comes to a head in world war
one which is one of the bloodiest
conflicts in all of human history so to
what degree did the enlightenment help
the world and to what degree did it not
get fulfilled or maybe in some way
things like world war one and world war
ii
were the birthing pangs the transition
state from the world before the
enlightenment and how close are we truly
to those ideals today
in a future video i'm going to talk
about that i'm going to talk about the
idea of human rights and how we as a
civilization have attempted to address
it after world war ii